- [Instructor] The function h is defined
for all real numbers in
the graph y is equal to
h of x, right over here.
That's what they're showing us.
And they ask us, what
is a reasonable estimate
for the limit as x approaches
negative seven of h of x,
and they give us some choices
for those reasonable estimates
including the possibility
that the limit does not exist.
So encourage you to pause the video
and see if you can work
through this yourself.
All right, now let's think
about what's going on.
So something is interesting
at x equals negative seven.
At x equals negative seven,
we have the function.
It is defined, but it is not continuous
with the rest of the function.
H of negative seven,
h of
negative seven is,
looks like a little bit,
it looks like it's like
negative four point something.
So it's approximately negative four point,
I don't know, looks like negative
4.1 something, something, something.
So that's what h of negative seven is.
And sometimes there's this temptation
to say, oh, whatever the function equals,
that must be what the limit is.
But this is actually a really good example
for showing the difference,
that many times, the limit
exists and is approaching
or it is a value different
than what the value
that the function takes on at that point.
And so let's think about the limit.
As x approaches negative seven
from smaller values of x,
so as x gets closer and
closer to negative seven,
it looks like the value of
our function is approaching
where we have this gap.
So it looks like our
function is getting closer,
the value of our function
is approaching this value
right over here.
Similarly, if we were to
approach from the left,
so for approach from more negative values,
it looks like the value of our function
is approaching that same thing.
And since it looks like it's
approaching the same value
whether we're coming
from more negative values
or less negative values,
we know, or we can assume,
or we have a good sense
that this limit exists.
We seem to be approaching the same value.
Now, it's a value different
than the actual value
of the function there.
The value of the function
there is at negative 4.1
or something like that.
Now, this looks like the
function itself is approaching,
this looks like, I don't, one point,
1.2,
1.3, something like that.
So now, let's look at our choices.
What's a reasonable
estimate for this limit?
Well, it's definitely not negative seven.
The function is definitely not approaching
y equals negative seven.
This is kind of a distractor choice
because this is what x is approaching.
X is approaching negative seven,
but we want to know what is
the function approaching?
What is the value of h approaching
as x approaches negative seven?
So let's rule that one out.
Negative 4.1,
so negative 4.1 is an interesting choice
because that's a good approximation
for what the actual value
of the function is there.
The function is defined there,
although it kind of jumps and
is defined right over here,
and it's discontinuous.
So this is more of what h,
this could be a reasonable
estimate for h of negative seven,
what the function
actually is defined to be
at x equals negative seven.
But as we approach x equals,
as we approach negative
seven, it is not approaching,
the value of the function does not seem
to be approaching negative 4.1.
So I'm gonna rule that one out.
Now, 1.3, that is what,
that is a pretty reasonable estimate
for what the function
seems to be approaching
as x gets closer and
closer to negative seven
'cause, you know, 6.9, 6.99,
or negative 6.9, negative
6.99, negative 6.9999,
from the right or from the left,
negative 7.1, negative 7.01,
negative 7.001, so on and so forth.
It looks like the value of
that function is approaching
approximately 1.3.
So I like
that choice right over there.
1.8, well, that's just another choice
but this, looking,
approximating where this is,
it definitely looks closer
to one than it does to two.
So I'd rule that one out.
And I would say that this limit does exist
because it looks like we're
approaching the same value
whether we're coming from below
or from above, so to speak.